on what looks like the surface of mars
the worst drought for 40 years is taking
hold
on land parched dry people are
struggling to survive
or fleeing
villages are emptying in this one
two-thirds of people have already left
[Music]
but some are too sick to move like
little decker
seven weeks old and severely
malnourished
her mother ian was also weak and
struggled to speak
the family is running out of food their
livestock has either died or stopped
producing milk like so many others here
under baking heat we met ismael mahmud
who's lived here 90 years and says it's
the worst drought he's ever witnessed
the deeper inland the worst the drought
we drove by one homestead after another
deserted by families as the drought
claimed their livestock
and this is the main homestead
and
probably they had children here they
gave birth to children's here one two
three kids here
and so you only leave if you have to
yeah yeah that is
it's the worst
in the worst situation and they you know
that is the last thing they can do
living leaving their homes they had to
leave that nursery they actually had no
choice truly they had no choice
outside one village we met the governor
of the region
its people desperately need help he told
us but the drought he says is being made
worse by the war in ukraine
it may look busy but in the only big
flower mill in somaliland they are
running out of grain
russia's blockade of ukraine means they
haven't had a shipment for three months
its silos are emptying and they may soon
have to stop grinding grain
maybe everybody will lose his job also
a somali population how they will get
food in general this war affected us as
a company as a company we are affected
by this war
that's it
if the mill shuts down somaliland will
lose its main source of bread
it's hard to think of a more graphic
illustration of the impact of russia's
war in ukraine on developing nations one
of the world's poorest countries
literally running out of grain its silos
standing empty while there is millions
of tons of grain stuck in ukraine unable
to get out
war and droughts now haunt somaliland
and the entire horn of africa
threatening a humanitarian disaster
unicef says without action the mass
death of children will be inevitable and
the people here know it's coming
at the last of three wells in this
village to have any water left camel
herders had dire predictions
dominic wagner